[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior a rencontré les présidents des
trois chambres consulaires afin
d'apporter des solutions de soutien et
d'accompagnement aux entreprises
réunionnaises pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences nous
voulons non pas mettre en place de
mesures nouvelles mais plutôt maintenir
parce que le département dès le départ
qui est très présent dans
l'accompagnement et donc nous voulons
maintenir ces aides
pendant les semaines les mois qui
viennent tant qu'il aura la crise est
bien le chèque d'accompagnement
alimentaire hygiène sera maintenu le
pass bien-être sera maintenu nous
voulons aussi continuer à soutenir la
commande publique à travers
l'amélioration de l'habitat en doublant
le nombre de dossiers d'amélioration
d'habitat sur tout le territoire de la
réunion et bien évidemment nous voulons
aussi faire en sorte que parce que il y
à une augmentation du coût du fret et
donc des marchandises des coûts de
matières premières nous voulons dans la
commande publique accompagner les
entreprises à travers les clauses de
révision de prix dans le domaine
agricole les mesures liées à la sécurité
alimentaire seront renforcés pour
pallier la fragilité due aux
importations
par rapport à notre dépendance aux
produits extérieurs notamment je pense
aujourd'hui au riz mais je peux penser
également la viande congelée aux oignons
à l'ail qui rentrent donc de m'inquiéter
pour ce produit n'est pas commun mais on
peut imaginer que des maths demain les
bateaux qui manque aujourd'hui pour le
bas le bâtiment vert puisse manquer pour
l'alimentaire donc c'est quoi ça donc il
faut très vite se mettre à travailler
sur un projet au nom produisent vers
cette fameuse souveraineté alimentaire
parmi les mesures décidées par le
département la prorogation le
renforcement de dispositifs majeurs tels
que le pass bien-être er plus donc c'est
un dispositif qui marche très bien et
nous avons proposé ce matin en présence
département de le prolonger le
dispositif car c'est une demande des
entreprises mais en même temps de
pouvoir aussi il a enjoint le dispositif
à d'autres activités de 2,2 de
l'artisanat tels que les fleuristes
métiers d'art mais bien dote donc le on
est bien entendu en attente que le
dispositif soit prolongée mais je pense
que là dessus a pas de difficultés et
aussi cet élargissement qui va toucher
d'autres métiers de l'artisanat la
décision du département ces deux doubles
effectivement le pecs et le rsa plus
mais au-delà de ça ce qui est important
ce que veulent les chefs d'entreprise
l'échelle dans vos journaux je veux
savoir comment les accompagnent comment
les aides entre l'état entre les
départements entre la région entre les
mairies entre les chambres consulaires a
fait que tout le monde nous puissions
mutualiser nos efforts et est les
accompagner dans les aide parce que les
entreprises s'ouvrent
[Musique]